hello dr. mother we're students from st.
your high school in New Jersey we're in
an advanced physics class and we would
like to know where do you as an
astrophysicist believe course originated
from and what scientific findings have
you tied to this position thank you for
your time and we hope you answer
question
so students from the Rose school you
want to know where did the quarks come
from well let me describe what a quark
seems to be if you take two protons and
you crash them into each other you can
find out that there seem to be made up
of smaller particles called quarks that
are held together by a force that seems
to be carried by other particles called
gluons now these particles can be made
in the in the collision so though we can
never get us a quark separated from
other quarks very far so these things
seem to be the building blocks of
ordinary matter particles that we see
today so theoretically if we imagine
what conditions might have been like in
the early universe where the
temperatures were extremely high and the
densities were extraordinary we could
imagine that the early universe was
composed of a kind of soup just made out
of quarks and gluons and any other
particles that might exist electrons and
other particles in that family so this
might be what the early universe is like
if so then the it was the extreme
temperatures and densities that made it
possible for quarks to exist along with
anti quarks and all of the other amazing
families of particles that might be
predicted then the universe expanded and
cooled off and the quarks came to group
together into ordinary particles like
protons and neutrons and eventually we
now have to make an accelerator to pry
them apart again